The rife function, we had a question come in that I missed, sorry, you know, who you are about the function of the rife, what does it do?
You know, is it, if it's killing bacteria things, is it killing my old cells?
Boy, we could have a couple hour discussion on the different theories and how rife frequency works.
There's multiple theories on how it works. I do cover this in some of my videos that are on our website on rife theory.
But just real clearly, is it damaging my old cells if I'm running a program?
I do not believe there's any damage to your normal cells. If I'm running the liver frequency cell program and it's running through normal liver frequencies, it's helping bring residents to my liver cells.
And it's going to help my liver cells function better.
Rife believed that running frequency of a cancer and his whole thing was trying to tune into that frequency of the cancer.
If he could hit that cancer with its own frequency, he would cause lysis of that cell.
And that's with how he believed he had success with cancer patients is that there was cell lysis.
Now, I do believe that that may occur, but I don't believe that that usually occurs.
If you do hit a cancer frequency with its own, cancer cell with its own frequency remember a cancer cell is your human body cells.
So if you have breast cancer, it is a breast cell that is in a rapid replication phase.
What are the beliefs of rife? And I do believe that this does take place many times is that when you hit the breast cancer cell with its own frequency of breast frequency,
you bring back normal residents to the cell and the cell stops rapidly replicating.
That's why you don't always get shrinkage of the tumor.
So remember what a cancer is. Cancer is cells that are in a rapid replication phase.
Well, therefore over time, there's a lot more cells. That's what a tumor is.
So a tumor is cells that are replicating, therefore they're getting more of them and they're getting larger.
And then with cancer, they're not going through normal apoptosis.
So you're getting a mass that's getting bigger and bigger and bigger.
And I've told you a hundred times that our goal is not to make the mass go away. That would be wonderful.
I just wanted to stop growing because if it stops getting bigger, then we know it's not replicating.
So if we can stop its replication, this rapid replication, it stops, quote unquote, being cancer.
So it fell off the definition of cancer since the definition of cancer is rapidly replicating cells.
So if we can get it to stop replicating, then we win.
So that's the goal of this altogether.
So one of the theories of rife is that if you hit a cancer cell with its own frequency, liver cancer or breast cancer,
if we residence back to that cell and it starts acting like a normal breast cell or liver cell again, it stops replicating.
That doesn't mean the mass is going to disappear.
So you have to get it out of your head that this mass in my breast may never go away.
And that's okay. We just got to get it to stop growing.
So that's part of the function of the rife with cancer.
No, there's at least two dozen other theories that all are viable and they probably are all applicable with how frequency medicine works with cancer.
So now nothing is going to work beyond God's desire for it to work in your life.
So we are dealing with that as well so we have to deal with what the sovereignty of God has played for the days of my life with this, but we're supposed to be doing our part.
So the rife is not a magic tool. It's not going to be a cure all for everything all the time, but it's going to be a great tool for us.